wer als journalist oder als journalistin
in russland über den krieg berichtet und
auch von krieg spricht oder von einer
invasion muss seit vergangenen freitag
damit rechnen im gefängnis zu landen
drakonische strafen wie präsident putin
mit seinem neuen mediengesetz verhängen
und das sind besorgniserregende
nachrichten sowohl für die russischen
journalistinnen und journalisten als
auch für die ausländischen sender bbc
und cnn haben ihre arbeit eingestellt
und wir von zdf und auch die idee haben
die berichterstattung aus moskau
ausgesetzt damit sie zu hause einen
besseren eindruck haben wie wir als
sender damit umgehen wie wir weiter
berichten können aus russland haben wir
unseren zdf-chefredakteur eingeladen ins
moma peter frey guten morgen hallo guten
morgen nach berlin schauen wir zu beginn
peter frey auf die situation in der
ukraine momentan sind dort unsere beiden
kollegen die kollegin katrin eigendorf
und am körper mit ihren teams vor ort
unter welchen umständen berichten die
beiden von dort ja ich bin den beiden
frau eigendorf und an körper natürlich
sehr sehr dankbar dass sie diesen job
machen zusammen mit ihren teams
producern kameraleuten dass es hoch
riskant aber sind sehr erfahrene
kolleginnen kollegen die auch schon den
anderen kriegs und krisengebieten waren
wir beobachten tag für tag wie die
entwicklung ist und ob wir es
verantworten können sie dort zu lassen
es ist natürlich wichtig dass man von
dem land berichtet in dem dieser
konflikt stattfindet aber wir haben zum
beispiel entschlossen die beiden
jedenfalls jetzt nicht nach kiew zu
schicken die situation dort oder auch in
der ost ukraine ist einfach zu
unkalkulierbar wir wollen in der ukraine
präsent sein aber wir müssen es so tun
dass die sicherheit dieser kollegen und
kollegen gewährleistet ist schauen wir
nach russland das dort verabschiedete
gesetz hat ja massive auswirkungen auf
westliche medien auch wir das zdf haben
die berichterstattung von vor ort
ausgesetzt was bedeutet das genau
ja im prinzip geht es auch hier um
sicherheit um die sicherheit der
kolleginnen und kollegen die aus diesem
büro in moskau berichten und deren
sicherheit ist in frage gestellt mit
diesem neuen mediengesetz das
mediengesetz stellt unter strafe die
verwendung von begriffen wie krieg oder
invasion wir wissen ja dass auch
russische medien gezwungen sind ganz
andere begriffe zu
benutzen die im grunde die wahrheit die
dort geschieht
verdreht und eben nicht den tatsachen
entspricht und wir wissen nicht genau
wie die russischen behörden auch mit
ausländischen korrespondenten umgehen ob
sie unter der gleichen drohung stehen
hier drohen drakonische strafen
gefängnisstrafen und solange das nicht
geklärt ist ob jemand der aus moskau
berichtet und darüber spricht wie die
wahrheit in diesem krieg ist auch diesen
strafen unterliegen wird haben wir in
der tat die berichterstattung durch
unsere korrespondentinnen und
korrespondenten vor ort ausgesetzt und
in der tat drastische drohungen das zdf
berichtet ja seit vielen jahren aus
moskau hat es denn eine vergleichbare
situation schon gegeben nein wir sind
seit etwa für sind gesagt genau 50
jahren in moskau das studio wurde 1972
eingerichtet auf dem höhepunkt des
kalten krieges und im grunde war es ein
zeichen der verständigung journalisten
auszutauschen nach russland und nach
deutschland um von dem anderen land
etwas zu erfahren und seitdem tun wir
das ununterbrochen durch alle höhen und
tiefen auch im afghanistan krieg anfang
der 80er jahre natürlich in der im
zeitalter von klassen ost und
perestroika gorbatschow die wilden
chaotischen 90er jahre in russland die
ära putin das zdf ist immer in moskau
geblieben wir haben aktuell berichtet
wir haben dokumentation gemacht die
aufsehenerregend waren unser publikum
sehr interessiert haben also es ist uns
sehr wichtig dort präsent zu sein auch
in der jetzigen situation aber wie
gesagt die sicherheit derjenigen die
berichten muss gewährleistet sein aber
wir sind bereit dorthin zurückzukehren
wenn es solche sicherheiten gibt und
haben übrigens auch für weitere
kolleginnen kollegen
akkreditierungs anträge gestellt die
aber bisher nicht bewilligt sind viele
fragen sich jetzt wie wir trotzdem
unmittelbar in diesen tagen und wochen
weiter berichten können vielleicht noch
ein wort dazu wie wir im zdf auch
weiterhin die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer über die geschehnisse in
russland informieren ja wir sind ja an
vielen plätzen ausgestattet mit
korrespondentinnen und korrespondenten
mit reportern und reportern natürlich
empfangen wir weiter bildmaterial aus
moskau unser büro arbeitet doch noch
dort noch wir beobachten die situation
auf der straße gerade heute morgen sind
die bilder ja von den festnahmen
gelaufen aber wir versuchen natürlich
auch die pose von der russischen
regierung des russischen militärs und
vor allem auch des russischen
präsidenten in unserem programm
wiederzugeben und senden entsprechende
interviewaussagen o-töne
pressekonferenzen darauf legen wir wert
es wäre natürlich viel besser werden
auch unsere korrespondenten aktiv von
dort berichten könnten aber solange
dieses pressegesetz gilt auch oder nicht
klargestellt ist dass es nicht für
ausländische korrespondenten gilt können
wir das nicht tun wir können ja nicht
die sicherheit unserer kollegen und
kollegen dadurch gefährden der
chefredakteur des zdf über die
schwierige berichterstattung aus
russland peter frey vielen dank